a couple of days ago i was invited to a
digital viewing of eldon ring it
included new screenshots the opportunity
for q day but most importantly i got to
view this stunning 16-minute gameplay
showcase that i'm not allowed to show
you for some reason which is weird
because this showcase is really well
made so i can only assume that you'll
see it soon
until then though you have this video
which will mainly be audio only so
hey while you listen for free to tab out
and browse soul arts which is my new art
book project now on kickstarter the
first thing the player does is approach
this grace checkpoint so for those of
you who don't know these are elden rings
version of bonfires but there's more to
it than that
because the open world is so vast a
gentle ray of light will shine from the
grace pointing you towards your next
main objective to be clear this doesn't
mean that your next objective will be
easy so sometimes it might be wise to
ignore the guidance and strike out on
your own path you know looking for loot
if you feel like you need to become more
powerful first
at points of lost grace you can summon
the fire keeper maiden of this game who
i got to see in a cut scene she phases
in like a spirit just like your horse
does and she sits down and removes her
hood revealing this light strawberry
blonde hair
these olive eyes with one of them being
scarred and shut tight she introduces
herself as melina and offers you an
accord ending the cutscene
she's a nest here maiden you'll see in
my interview every journalist would have
learned different things from their
interview but in my interview it was
revealed that you can level up at
melinda and customize things like your
spirit summons and equipped weapon
skills while you sit at a grace graces
also refill this game's equivalent of an
estus flask but since graces are a
little bit harder to come by than
bonfires are you can also get a bit of
health back by defeating mobs of enemies
which from software says should keep you
exploring a little bit longer
beyond graces there is another more
traditional hub location and i'm showing
it on screen now here npcs you meet in
the outside world will come to visit you
similar to places like firelink shrine
in the center there's what looks like
this really large grace checkpoint and
it has threads connected to weapons that
are lying askew in the middle of the
table i was thinking that maybe every
time you find a grace in the outside
world a new thread is added or maybe the
light grows larger but that's just
speculation
around the table are chairs presumably
where npcs will come to sit
and i have to say this room is just so
visually distinct from other hub worlds
that we've seen before
it's ornate it's elegant and i think
that really befits a tarnished because
you are a character who is striving to
get this sort of dignity back
i love that after leaving the grace
checkpoint your character starts running
and they summon their mount while moving
with this smooth fast animation it's so
easy to imagine this being used mid
combat whenever you need a burst of
speed to get away or to close a gap and
once you see the player actually riding
around you get such a thrill from seeing
that because the previous trailer was
really good but it was cut so often that
you couldn't really get a sense of the
vastness of the world but in this video
you get to see the player transition
from exploring that open world into
exploring camps and dungeons and random
encounters around the place it just
feels so much more fulfilling to see the
game that way and unsurprisingly this
video revealed a ton of new information
during the presentation from software
made it clear that generally in terms of
horseback combat you might prefer to
fight on horseback when you're against
larger foes where hit and run tactics
are effective and you might prefer to
dismount to take out multiple enemies
more carefully
out of combat you and your horse have a
sprint that doesn't use up your stamina
and this is supposed to help you
traverse the world in combat however
stamina will come back into play and
then on horseback you can easily fire
arrows you can fire off sorcery and you
can of course swing your weapon so i was
shown horseback combat in a fight
against this giant wyvern which starts
as this small speck in the sky in the
distance and then flies down it
obliterates this group of hollows
standing nearby
and the fight begins
from software are calling these field
bosses they're mini bosses varying in
difficulty that can be fought in the
open world freely and the second field
boss in the trailer is fought at the end
of a co-op showcase and it fights
similarly to those dragon kin that are
in archdragon peak it it's capable of
extending its body in a really surreal
way and when the two characters defeat
this field boss it leaves behind a grace
checkpoint which i thought was
interesting at some point in the trailer
the player brings up the map which has
this really
beautiful honestly hand-drawn style
and looks absolutely gorgeous this map i
found from octopath traveler is the
closest thing i found
i obviously can't show the actual map
one of the most interesting things i
noticed on the map was this enormous
ocean area with ships and even what
looked like a path demarcated on it it
made me wonder if some sort of ocean
exploration is possible maybe swimming
is like it is in sakura and then also on
the map obviously you have your location
and the direction you're facing and from
software mentions that you can set
markers on the map to help you with
exploration they say you might prefer to
mark off a forest that has valuable
crafting ingredients so you can come
back later or maybe mark off places with
a dangerous boss you haven't defeated
yet marked areas on the map also show up
as pillars of light in the distance and
this helps you move closer towards them
this is similar to breath of the wild or
fortnite as well i think
you don't actually fill out this map by
exploring instead you collect map
fragments that are scattered around the
world they're clearly trying to build
out their loot tables here to encourage
exploration and to encourage uh dungeon
diving for example and finally once
you've discovered a location you can
easily just fast travel there all in all
the map is a big step up from the
previous map we got which was securos
a map that was pretty useless but i have
to say eldon ring is drawing heavily
from what they learned with securo that
much is so obvious you know they're
adding a jump button they're adding
stealth and both of these things play a
huge part in differentiating this game
from dark souls and you see that in the
combat section so this section has the
player dismount on a tall cliff they
pull out their binoculars and they start
to scout the enemy camp below them
planning their assault to complement
their stealth something called sleep
arrows have been added they allow you to
quietly incapacitate enemies from a
distance which gives you an opportunity
to sneak past them without having to
kill them although if you do want to
kill them you can just one shot them if
they're a lesser enemy while they're
asleep if that doesn't seem overpowered
enough you can attack midair like
insecure you can shoot your bow mid-air
as well
you're basically sakura wearing armor
both sakura and dark souls had combat
arts but in my opinion neither sakura or
dark souls got weapon arts right however
eldon ring might
in this game they're called skills and
they're like weapon arts except that
they can be assigned to any weapon in
this trailer the character performs wind
blasts from a scimitar and they deal a
thunderstrike from a pole arm i think
all of this stuff will help your
character feel really customized and
really themed as well
again you probably find these things
hidden around the world which adds to
the loot table in the game another set
of things you can find hidden around the
world are spirits of the deceased these
unlock different sets of npcs for
summoning and these can only be summoned
in difficult areas that have these
obelisks present some spirits are tanky
some are aggressive some arranged and
some appear to come as a swarm in one
example from the video the player
summoned a set of like six friendly npcs
these phantoms caused chaos they allowed
the player to weave in and out of all
the enemies they were facing and allow
the player to deal damage more freely
the player in this scene was dealing
damage with a twin blade by the way so
i'm glad they're bringing that back from
dark souls 2. according to from software
spirit summons use the fp system you'll
remember from dark souls basically the
mana system the strongest summons use
more fp and weaker summons use less this
might make it a bit less overpowered
than i thought at first
since if you summon spirits you might
not have access to your spells and
skills
still spirit summons are probably very
powerful by nature and i anticipate
elden ring in general will be far more
accessible to new players just because
you have so many ways of overcoming
adversity in this game a few sections of
the video showcase co-op and this is
something i'm really excited for because
it just seems less instanced than in
previous games in the video two players
sneak through the forest that you see in
this screenshot they're avoiding these
large terrifying creatures who are
patrolling the area and then later we
delve into this underground dungeon with
our partner and we're avoiding these
sends fortress star traps and ambushes
together
from software have previously mentioned
that they want to reduce the friction
required for co-op removing requirements
like having humanity or embers and i
just hope they take this all the way i
hope they make it easy to bring our
friends into our world and then keep
them there i did notice that after
defeating a field boss your partner
didn't seem to disappear finally we make
our way to stormvale castle the legacy
dungeon of this first open world if the
open world of eldon ring is like dark
souls with a horse then legacy dungeons
are dark souls with a jump because from
what i saw they're way more vertically
inclined than ever before with multiple
paths sprawling left and right and these
paths are laid up and down as well
a character talks to an npc as soon as
they arrive at the castle and the npc
recommends that we take the back way
into the castle the player however opts
for the main gate instead and they're
instantaneously shot down by ballista
arrow fire i think you could roll
through this but our player quickly
changes their mind and they take the
back way instead the back way through
the castle has way more sakura elements
you're using jumps to get over rubble
you're avoiding guards that signal the
alarm and you're using sleep arrows to
sneak past giant enemies and waiting for
you at the end of all of this is the
heavily armed demigod whose full intro
cinematic we get to see this time one of
the really cool things i noticed here
was a new sort of counter-attack
animation that can be performed after
blocking it's this one from the earlier
trailer
basically when you block an attack in
alden ring with a weapon it seems like
you can quickly follow up with a unique
attack animation and i love this idea
because in dark souls whenever you
blocked an attack with your weapon it
didn't go well you know it did a lot of
stamina damage it did a lot of chip
damage but now in elden ring there is an
offensive benefit to blocking an attack
like this with a weapon it's not ideal
but it helps you get back into combat
and keep that pace going so in
conclusion i kind of take back what i
said about this not being big dark souls
elden ring is kind of big dark souls but
it's also secular souls way more than i
expected actually and it really does
feel like the culmination of everything
that they've learned up to this point
and
i think everyone who has seen this
footage will echo that sentiment i just
can't wait for you to see it i think
it's a bit silly that it hasn't been
shown publicly but anyway before i go i
want to ask would you guys listen to an
audiobook if i narrated it i'm asking
this because soon you will have the
opportunity to
a couple of weeks ago i revealed our
kickstarter for soul arts which is this
premium art book filled with all of the
best art from the art competitions i've
been running the last few years it's
also a book filled with short stories on
every page and now as a reward for all
the support you guys have given that
project i'm planning on narrating the
entire thing for backers to enjoy on
youtube this is a new part of the
digital edition of the book which almost
every single backer will have access to
by default
so please enjoy the hinterlands it's one
of many short stories that i'm writing
for soul arts enjoy
the player begins a journey through the
outskirts of the hinterlands a murky
wetland brimming with decay and rot
once the hinterlands were home to the
crows a wise and perceptive clan
renowned for wielding weapons forged
from cyderite they coveted this shining
metal and would go to great lengths to
obtain it stashing it in their homes for
safe keeping it was said to have fallen
from the sky and the crows worshiped
anything that originated from such a
heavenly realm
one day a herald arrived in their
primitive town preaching of blood
healing and exceptional medicine
developed in a nearby town called yarnam
the crows had no need of such a thing
and the herald soon left
not long after his visit the land
softened crops started to wilt and crows
fell afflicted by a strange illness that
had them coughing blood and ash
suspecting a ploy to empty their town so
it could be pillaged of ciderite the
remaining tribes folk departed for yanum
nevertheless forced from the place they
once called home their sick required
healing but a crow never forgets the
face and the healing church will rue
their murder
you